i eat so much fruit now working from
home
i just have like a basket of these
little guys beside me all day
okay are we good are we recording
yeah i'm also gonna make you a mod
moderator
yeah all right sounds good so welcome to
the first
uh flutter hype house dating panel
um how this will go i'm not really sure
i don't have a dating perspective but
i'm here to just kind of like
filter questions to you guys um why
don't we do quick intros like
not life story quick intros for
everybody start with ari
we'll go through get to know everybody
real quick and then we'll get
sorry if you can hear my dog barking by
the way um
he's kind of little man syndrome
big ego but anyways uh my name is ari
uh i'm the spokes person for flutter
dating i
like to give relationship and dating
advice i kind of wanted to
essentially get all the best creators on
tick tock together to
kind of set the record straight for
dating and
i and relationships um i'm from
california
i'm from the bay area and like brian i
am
a tech bro but uh brian probably will
introduce himself
later but yeah that's pretty much theirs
to me
all right uh my name is star oh did you
do this one
no you're good bro go ahead okay go
ahead you're good my name is star
jesse taylor uh i'm a
tick tucker you say i do extra
dating coaching and spiritual coaching
and teach people all kinds of awareness
so they don't get manipulated by
other people's manipulative dating
advices or get manipulated by
people who are using those dating
advices
on them
i don't know if you can still hear me or
because i cannot hear you anymore so my
name's
pearl and then i do like relationship
quizzes
so i basically made like why do we break
up quizzes
um just different quizzes people could
send to like
the person they're in a relationship
with
i'm also from chicago if anyone cares so
um amanda do you want to go next
sure uh my name is amanda i am
a holistic anxiety coach so i work with
um high impact high value individuals
usually leaders
and then i do digital content for the
kids and
uh most of my content is either around
social anxiety internal anxiety or
dating anxiety
and i'm in new york and i nominate
casey hi everyone
so uh introduction my name is casey i'm
bored and raised and still living in las
vegas nevada
so growing up in law space you get to
meet a lot of interesting characters
and i think that might provide a little
bit of outside perspective into the
dating world
in regards to the tick tock content i
make it's really whatever comes into my
head a lot of it's
either self-improvement or just fun
facts about
the life around us and for my nomination
next will be
jackson what's up guys um my name is
jackson olsen i'm from connecticut
but i'm playing college baseball in
florida for uh stetson university
i'm currently getting my master's in
marketing i think or accounting i'm not
really sure yet
um so for tick tock i basically the same
thing
i basically post whatever comes to my
head um i post a lot of relatable stuff
for college kids i mix some baseball
stuff in there but i don't really
i don't really do a lot of sports
content um
so yeah and i'm 23. so that's that's me
i nominate uh dante what's up guys
i'm dante um i'm from salt lake city
utah i was also a college athlete i
played college basketball in north
dakota
but i've been home for about a year now
that's when i started tick tock and my
content's
mostly about some stuff's college things
related just for younger kids
or kids in high school too but a lot of
it's based around relationships and just
like women knowing their worth
and how guys should properly treat women
i think it's super important
because i think we're definitely lacking
that um
yeah that's me i'm 21 by the way
and then i think albert has to go too
good hi my name's albert um i'm from
calgary alberta that's in canada if you
guys didn't know
but um yeah i've been on tick tock for
just under a year
and if you've seen me you've probably
seen my mom um we do a lot of content
together just
have fun um show that you're never too
old to have a good time
just to kind of lay back and relax so we
try and relate to people that way and
show
a good mother and son relationship
because i think that will resonate in
terms of all your other relationships
that you have towards women
so i think we try and show that off and
um yeah we just have fun with it and
i'm also uh 23 as well
yeah albert and his mom are just
actually the most precious people i've
ever watched on tick tock still
like you guys you've got swag too bro
you got some good drinks i know
like i'm rather than popping on my fyp
like crazy him and his mom and i'm just
i'm liking all that [ __ ]
every time it comes up automatic like
don't even have to watch all of it
she loves it she loves the tic toc she
should have her own account to be honest
get her on it yeah i got to
all right swinging back to me my name is
brian my name is
i'm still choking on this one okay i'll
make it
okay my name is brian i live in san
francisco um
i i work in tech as well i'm a data
scientist most of my tick tock content
is probably
sharing some sort of data or answering
questions about linkedin
stuff like that i have not done much
dating app uh dating
relationship advice stuff but you know
here i am so
how i think um this is going to go in my
head
is we'll start off with a theme um
today's theme will be
kind of relationships around the
holidays i'll start off with a couple
prompts
and then in terms of y'all wanting to
chime in if you have a perspective on
the question
let's try to use the reaction do you
know how to use the reactions stuff
like i don't mean like give me an
indication
does it work for y'all can i see it okay
give me an indication if there's
something
you want to say i can call on you um
just so we don't come in all at once and
then
um also if you want to type in the chat
as someone else is talking to
um the person who's talking can then
address that person
hold up hold up the other tech bro here
doesn't know how to do this
oh how do i you see the green share
screen at the bottom
two buttons to the right there's this
reactions button
okay guys we're learning this is great
already
okay okay so i'll probably start off
with the theme
and then uh ari wanted to play a couple
of tick tocks
that uh we're going to categorize as
questionable
dating advice uh we can talk about some
of that too and then
wrap up where some non-holiday grab back
questions also if you all have questions
to bring up
we can go for that too everybody sound
good
not okay so around the holidays let's
start off with some data
my favorite thing so there was a study
in 2010
where this dude poured over like a
hundred thousand facebook profiles
and he found that the biggest spikes in
splits have been won right before
valentine's day
just before spring break and another
significant spike showed up shortly
before the christmas holidays
does what why do you all think that is
and is there a personal story also that
you can share in terms of like
well is i don't know is there a make or
break thing right before a holiday or
like what
i feel like it's for me it seems a
little arbitrary because it's just a
date and there's plenty of these dates
around the year
but what do you think about these
certain holidays kind of makes or breaks
relationships
amanda no you have to look at the other
side
you can go for it star correct
okay i actually made a video about this
today because i read
the slack notes and i was talking about
valentine's day
and you have to look at the holidays
because what you said is
from the data they broke up just before
valentine's day
or before after valentine's day sorry
after valentine's day
or before christmas right
that's what you said valentine's day
before spring break
before christmas holidays yeah so what
happens is
most people or this is i'm not going to
say that okay this is all right
i don't like data in itself anyway
because i think we should treat
individuals
as individuals but valentine's day
is a thing where people i assume that
these
people wanted to break up before
valentine's day
they just didn't want to feel lonely on
valentine's day
so most people are in relationships
because
they don't feel good inside and that's
why they choose the relationship
so they try to uh they try to find the
value that they can't find in themselves
in the other person and that's why most
relationships don't work out
so what i assume a lot of these couples
girlfriends boyfriends whatever
we're not uh
happy already before valentine's day but
they knew this event
or better said their mind knew the voice
in their mind knew
oh i know valentine's going to come up i
just don't want to feel lonely
i just don't want to feel without my
partner and then come
together i made a video about this today
i don't know what anybody else thinks
about this but this is my assumption
based on what's going on the before
christmas i just think that
they like oh meet the family that's all
too much
but like i said the data that's just my
assumption of valentine's day
anyone else has any things to say about
that
i i i agree with that like general line
of thought
what happens typically with like
socialized pressure
is we like and i'm only going to speak
for western culture for a second but
we've social
we've been socialized to like make these
landmark holidays
i mean they're important right but like
mentally emotionally socially we're
we're taught that they mean a lot more
so whether
we're getting that pressure from friends
or family or that pressure is being
self-imposed
there's a lot of like unsaid stuff
that's getting written between the lines
when it comes to holidays meet the
friends
emotional expectations plans and then
all of the miscommunications that come
from that and so
if there are two people that may not
have been on the same page beforehand
and everyone's got their own
communication issues so it's like
the perfect cocktail for if both people
aren't independently strong
and good communicators shit's gonna
break
and that's okay right it's not like oh
my god it's the end of the world but
i think like on the individual level if
you find yourself feeling that pressure
prior to
holiday breakup which i actually am
really here for that data because
it's like generalizations right they're
generalizations because like a majority
they have the have a similar experience
i think the learning from that is like
okay if i'm going into
a holiday relationship or feeling that
desire to break up
first rule is check in with yourself
it's like where is this this fear coming
from and what do i need to do say or
communicate
and then i know someone else had their
hands raised sorry
yeah i think that um
largely i i definitely agree with the
whole pressure especially
around the holidays and i think that
maybe it comes down to socio-economic
differences because you know when it com
if you're living with someone you're
doing joint
finances so you obviously and then money
becomes a huge issue
people have different expectations
whether it be you know
hanukkah whether it be christmas whether
it be kwanzaa whether it be you know
valentine's day whether it be whatever
you guys celebrate
i think that there is a large pressure
to maybe meet someone's expectations and
i think also mission does play a huge
role in how we tend to um
emphasize like what is important to us
and for me
especially growing up you know
valentine's day was something that we
always celebrated especially in western
culture
and as i got older i kind of understood
you know not being able to do
the grand gestures that a lot of people
talk about on valentine's day or what is
associated with love and romance
because i was a broke college kid i
didn't have the money to get my
significant other or whoever i was
dating at the moment like
a huge extravagant gift however like now
that i'm
older i kind of see like there's no
point
and so i think that this is where people
tend to split off because
a your significant other could you know
expect a
huge gift they could expect like
something extravagant
for me personally like this has actually
helped me in my relationships where i've
said you know i don't expect you to get
anything for me and that's great
but i've also seen it break up other
people or other couples and they're like
why didn't you do this for me i expect
this and i think there is a large
expectation when it
when it comes to the holidays and
whatnot and maybe i'm just talking in
circles but
i do think it's a large social economic
difference as well um when it comes to
just holidays and expectations and the
pressure that accompanies it as well so
let's talk about gifts real quick how
stressed
do you all get with giving a gift to
somebody
in terms of picking it out or
determining if it's the right
level for where you got you feel y'all
are at
uh let me know jackson you should chime
in on this one
you there we go there we go
i would say that even if your
significant other says like
i don't want anything special this year
like you don't have to go like overboard
it's like you still feel this like you
feel like you have to and you feel like
you have to go overboard and it's like
you think that that's how they're gonna
see that like how you love how you love
them and like how much you love them
and so when i get a gift i've had two
girlfriends in the past i had one in
college
and um one in high school and
i spent i spent all my money on gifts
for them and i spent all my money on
going out to dinner
and getting the biggest extravagant gift
but now i realize that like it's more
about the thought and like
obviously it's it's tough to say that
because yeah it's the thought that
counts but like
a diamond ring is cooler than a sweater
from macy's like
you have to you have to think about that
too so i think you have to really talk
to your partner and say like hey like
this is
this is my financial state that i'm in
right now i don't know what you're in
right now but this is what i'm in
this is what i can afford it's not this
isn't based on how much i love you
because obviously i'm dating you and i'm
i'm with you or i'm talking to you
whatever state you're in
and you just have to have really good
communication back and forth about that
because you can't
you cannot be going out as a 21 year old
22 year old how old you are
and spending all your money on just
gifts for this person like
if you're gonna spend money spend it
going to disney world with your
significant other like spend it on value
instead of just like these tangible
things that
will go away like you just have to you
have to think about that so
i'm not the best i don't know about
anyone else but some of the best gifts
that like i've gotten
haven't really been the most expensive
like they've just been like extra
thoughtful
does anyone else feel like that or do
you feel like it's like monetary only
i you know someone was asking me the
other day about the best gift that i've
ever
gotten and it was really just about the
thought and even like the funniest gifts
that i've gone i remember the most
but i feel like there's a bigger
pressure to find a funny and sentimental
gift especially for me
because it's like i feel as if if i'm
not
also sorry i just interrupted everyone
by the way i didn't i forgot to raise my
hand
um but yeah i feel like
if i if there's a difference between
spending like three hundred dollars
versus like spread spending like what
fifteen twenty dollars
and i think that i would personally like
the little like fifteen dollar gift more
than three hundred dollar gift that's
just me
um yeah
also i've gone to car mirror before as a
gift that was really weird
but yeah i was gonna like briefly chime
in
about love languages and i'm not gonna
get into like the whole five
i love those that's like i i was hoping
someone would bring it up
so like okay very briefly there's five
different ways people can like receive
or express
love gift giving is one of them which is
the one that we're focusing on
and like when you talk about how you
relate or like
experience love it to ari's point it's
not
necessarily about like the financial
value of the gift it's like
the feeling that you get because all
that we're trying to do when you give a
gift
is like communicate hey love you i'm
thinking about you
or like you were on my mind and
it's so interesting because like it can
be your love language to give
gifts but not necessarily to receive
them
um which is how i am i like want to give
everyone gifts all the time
i don't care about getting them um
so i think there's like something there
to like think about or maybe talk about
too which is like
you know what do you do how do you
express love when it's like
not just
background noise um pearl wait what what
is
is gifts one of your love languages no
it's like the worst one of mine like
like the one i got the least
for me like i don't feel like i like i
like
people that like do things for me
like like um what is the acts of service
yeah so i feel like it's like
easy to buy a gift like your real
friends are the ones that help you move
you know
um
are you getting more thoughts or you're
just glad are we still doing the hand
raising thing i feel like i'm in school
i don't know
yeah we don't have to um but um just
like
yeah i didn't even know how to come in
do this with the hand raising
let me see okay um i believe
go for it
if such a thing as giving a gift
is a make or break in the relationship
then the foundation of the relationship
there was no foundation anyway to me and
it's more like things that make up the
relationship
is more like loyalty and can you trust
the partner
do you guys can you express yourself
freely together
and i feel like if you have that kind of
connection
it doesn't matter what
a person will give you like that's not
something where you're gonna be like
oh i'm sad they didn't give me that on
valentine's day if they don't give you
anything they're probably
if you have that kind of connection
we'll communicate to you why oh i had
i forgot this was that day that day if
such a thing as a made-up day a created
day
like valentine's day is
gonna make or break like or admit
it's like if the girlfriend is like oh
talking to her girlfriends
man i like john less because he didn't
give me the diamond ring he gave me
uh whatever a card with a trip to
whatever then this is not
a true like healthy relationship
and if anyone's like oh yeah you should
buy this or you should buy that
that's so superficial and when i'm
saying superficial
not like on the basis of what we in
society think is superficial on
the level of your relationship if you
are not disconnected to your partner
where
such a thing is like a make or break
then
it's just the whole idea
is not making sense of a relationship
i think john wanted to say something
earlier
um yeah hey guys um
something similar to what amanda said
with the love languages
and i realized like gift giving is one
of the ways like i love giving gifts
but i feel like they're really
thoughtful or i'll get something
creative but i
still like when someone gives me a
really like brave thoughtful gift
like i just had a birthday and a couple
people bought
different cards and a couple small
things but when they picked out the card
it was like totally spoke my language
and it was kind of like
someone's there totally like easy card
and that's something that i love
and so like for me that would have been
that card means so much more to me than
it would if they gave me like a 25
gift card or something to a restaurant
so um
[Music]
in the thought money gift and i if i
give someone gifts
i'll do the same thing but what i've
also found is someone some people don't
like receiving gifts
so if it's really thoughtful and you
think it would be really good for them
and it's not
then
and like sometimes it's like you have to
kind of know your know your audience and
know that person so
um i think um lastly i'll say there was
a
podcast episode i listened to on gift
giving
that there's some there's a lot of power
and gift-giving in like
yes in romantic relationships but also
in like business relationships
because sometimes when you're working
with people in business they might be a
millionaire
but what's something you can give them
that will make them think
and so really getting good at uh
giving gifts can really take you a long
ways
but what about the game of like oh what
do you
like when you sometimes ask like what do
you want and they're like oh don't do
[ __ ] for me or like i don't want
anything or like don't worry about it
but then you know it's some it's kind of
a game where you're like yeah they
usually they want so how do you
determine if like this is someone that
actually wants something
or is just saying that but you know you
still have to do something
have you all been in that situation a
bunch as well
going to like go or not
they want to say something so i've been
in that situation with one of my
girlfriends she
always said that she wanted nothing and
for me what i tried to do was just
listen like
not just around the holidays or anything
like that but throughout the year
to the little cues and little things
that she said she wanted or just the
things that excited her and i'd try and
get her something of that sort and then
she was super surprised and she enjoyed
it
even though she told me she didn't want
a gift but i think it just comes down to
listening communication at that point
yeah i did ask have like a note on my
phone
for when i hear stuff for random friends
just through the year
just so i don't get stressed out when
it's gift giving time all right did you
want to say something
yeah sorry i was really stressed out
because we were running out of time and
i was like trying to like get out my
card
and because i don't have unlimited
minutes but now we do but anyways um
something that i did for my last
ex-boyfriend was every single time
we had a milestone whether it be a fight
whether we grew as a couple whether it
be that you know
if i experienced something where we
just you know something that we
experienced together i'd write him a
letter
and it could be any day any week every
week whatever one would be
and actually turned out to be a really
sentimental gift and this is just a gift
idea that i'm throwing out there
but i ended up giving it to him
during our breakup because i was like i
put so much work into this
and so i don't know that's just
something that you guys can do
but yeah
all right cool so we can we can move on
to another uh
let's go into holidays and family
actually
um because that's another big and
stressful part
especially around the holidays and so
question here is
what is your thinking in terms of when
you should introduce
a partner to a family member around the
holidays and what are some of the other
things that you think about
is it like the conversation around the
dinner table is it kind of how they
match up culturally what are your
thoughts on that
um i can chime in i think i think for me
personally
like being in a relationship you kind of
already have that in the back of your
head before anything happens like
for me when i like question the person
that like i want to be with or i'm gonna
be with
or currently with i think before i even
try and get into that relationship i
kind of asked myself like
would my parents and like my family
members
um kind of see that there'd be good fit
for me
and like they'd be accepting and
everything because i think at the end of
the day
yeah it's gonna be just you and that
partner
um in the long term but i think it's
very important for them to see the
values and the morals in that person as
well
because sometimes people can be like
blind by love i guess
and they they can't see some things that
other people could see
so i think it's very important um to get
like a outlet and a
third um third-person perspective and
different perspective
in that person so um yeah i think
definitely during the holidays it's
definitely like a very big step in terms
of introducing them to your family
so i think you have to be like really
prepared for that and have proper
communication
and even if they're comfortable in doing
that
i think if the relationship is strong
they would be willing and would want to
um like see your family and get to know
more of you because obviously
you had a past before you guys met so i
think it's important to kind of
figure out the person's whole self and
the people that import them in their
lives because if you're going to be with
them
they're important people in their lives
should be your important people
in your lives as well
yeah i so the question was
um how do we integrate people into
holiday traditions or when to
introduce them
yeah the question is um that's a big
part of holidays in terms of like when
should you introduce your partner
to your family if it's if you are
spending time with your family [ __ ] how
should you include your partner in that
i something that i kind of worry about
just personally myself is like
you know what if my partner doesn't
really get along with my parents or what
if they have a different you know
upbringing and
i think especially with one of my
biggest worries
i haven't brought anyone home yet for
the holidays is like what if they have a
very different
upbringing in terms of religion and
they're like well you don't
have that in your family you know that's
not a core part of your family so i
don't want to
date you or you know you know families
fight my family
does tend to fight sometimes i think
that's very
that's something that's like you know
people deal with and so sometimes i do
get worried like on the holidays and
that's just something that i personally
worry about i don't know if people also
deal with that in this
zoom chat but um i don't know if people
think about that but that's always what
comes to mind when i'm like
if i'm going to bring someone home as
well
yeah ari just like chime in on that too
that's a very very normal fear that i
see a lot with clients and it's tough
right it's like
i i joke and say that like everyone's
family is crazy it's just like different
flavors of crazy
and it's a really human fear to be
afraid that like the person we love is
going to judge us for
where we came from yeah and the truth is
there's like
there's always going to be a sliver of
potential or validity in that is like
everyone has the propensity to
potentially judge someone
as do you to other people so the the
first and like primary solve for that is
being really clear within yourself about
how why you love this person or care
about this person if you're like not in
the love phase yeah like why they're
important to you
and if there are things one of the best
pieces of advice that i've ever been
given and i share it with everyone is
like
if there is something potentially
fixable that you can get ahead of
get the hell ahead of it so like talk to
your partner and be like hey i'm feeling
a little bit
i'm really excited that you're going to
meet my family
um my parents have different political
views
than you and i do and that's it's really
hard for me so i just wanted to
prepare you for that going in i totally
understand if it makes you uncomfortable
know that i'm going to be here alongside
you right it's like
and i'll have clients sometimes because
that's like easy to say for me right now
because i'm not in it
but the work where listen i've
for sure faltered myself is like it's
hard to find that language when you're
already upset
so you have to be proactive
about your fear before it's actually
time to face it
like i have clients script out some
stuff like i'll have them text it i had
a girl text
i have a girl who wants to ask a girl on
a friend date and she's like i don't
want to seem weird what do i say
and i'm like text me as if i'm that
friends and i'm going to give you some
feedback
clear is kind the more simplified honest
and like
upfront you can be with what your fears
are if you're with the right person
they're going to be like
cool got you this is gonna be nuts let's
go in together
yeah that's really true i mean i had a
really
kind of terrifying experience with my
very first boyfriend because his mom
like it was his graduation okay um i was
a freshman
in college she was a graduating senior
um
and then like the first thing that
happened when i met the mom was
she was like why are you late and i was
like uh because there's traffic
and basically it was mother's day the
next day
i and i already had told him i'm like i
am kind of terrified of your mom based
on what you said about her
um and he's like okay don't worry like
she's she's nice
i made a joke to her and i said hey
don't worry like i reminded drew to get
you
like flowers for mother's day you know
and
she kind of just gave me a dirty look
and ever since
that day she has drove that into
every single conversation of ours and
i'm like
and that's where i just have general
anxiety and this is where you can come
in
but i have general anxiety about meeting
like my significant other's parents or
like even introducing my significant
others
to my parents because it's like i'm
afraid that i'm not gonna get accepted
and i'm sure a lot of people in this
chat
might deal with the same worry and like
even because i was dating someone who is
religious
they decided the mom decided same mom by
the
way
decided to use that as a basis for
kind of telling me that number one i'm
the devil that
i am not a good partner that they should
as a grounds to break up with me
and it kind of just is really terrifying
um
but yeah like i i think about that a lot
and so that's kind of where i'm like
you know when is the right time maybe
i've had a very different
experience from all of you guys but like
personally for me i get terrified when
people
bring their parents into the equation
because i'm just like all my avoiding
tendencies
come out and i'm like peace i'm good bye
i'm gonna just
hide you know so
john wants us to be oh sorry
okay all right um i was i feel that same
thing
and i think that there's part of um
part of what we do when we grow up
is we try to make our friends happy and
we try to please our parents and so now
we're in a significant relationship with
a significant other
and it's words like unless we've i think
there'll always be some part at least
about me is like always trying to make
my parents happy
so now i see this other mother mother
and father
figure or this like role with this other
significant other and so
part of that is almost trying to like
make them happy because you want
them to like you because you're now
dating that significant
other and so or that their their
daughter or son or whoever
and so i think that that has something
to play with like
goes into play a little bit so kind of
realizing that like okay
you know what there's this is who i am
this is who they are and then just
being here being yourself and being a
decent human being and i think that
sometimes people might not like you when
you meet their
significant other just because they
probably like you know if they brought
home
you know four or five [ __ ] in the
past you're just going to be number six
and so you might have to make up for it
but at the same time realizing that if
that if you're not then you're not
so that's kind of what i want to add on
to that
all right any other thoughts on holidays
family or gifts or we're pretty good on
this at this point
star
[Music]
star you're still muted yeah now i'm
like there you go they just gave me the
options can you hear me
you guys see me
because that should be unneeded now but
i cannot hear you
yeah we can hear you okay great
um so i think that causes
a lot of overthinking too if you want to
get
the approval of the mom and i know in
our society
that's a natural thing right it's it
seems natural
to want the approval of the families
your partners satisfied
so you guys have a comfortable
thanksgiving
or christmas but that pattern
is so outside it is so
like its circumstances and circumstances
always shift and i know this sounds so
like general but i'm gonna make it more
specific
so let's say i have a good relationship
with my partner
and we are going to for christmas
right but my partner already knows me
like if my partner didn't already
know me my partner wouldn't have invited
me
to that gathering to
have christmas with their family skiing
excited about me as a person
and i'm excited about my partner as a
person now it's completely
out of my hands who birthed my partner
the mom and dad of my partner situation
is completely out of my hands i didn't
say okay before i came into this
physical reality i was not like
okay that partner once i'm with i want
the parents to be cool too i want the
parents to be nice
so let's say you get into this situation
where like i'm sorry i didn't know who
said that i think it was john
where six five or six people beforehand
were [ __ ] and now you
have to make up for it right so
that's kind of a problem of the parents
because they already
in their mind have a
certain idea of
who the daughter brings home so let's
say i'm coming
and they just completely like i don't
know they don't
they don't they don't respect me
literally if if that affects the
relationship of my partner who knows me
then that's the problem my partner
because the partners should see
oh they already have this belief system
about who they bring
but i like i always had like
[Music]
um experiences
i'm just saying it's way too much
anxiety
for the person to overthink
all those things and to change yourself
for the parents the parents will
see who you are once you act the way you
are
once you follow your own talk like they
let you receive who you are
oh i have to do this to
get value from the time and that pattern
will be in your relationship to them
because
then to make that person like you you
will literally
pretend to be someone else too does does
that make sense
because i don't want to like and saying
there but i wanted to sing if that makes
sense to everybody
i wasn't able to get all of it so i
think your connection is cutting in and
out a little bit
um but maybe we'll never get all of it
but what you did said
made sense to me um let's move
on pearl did you want to say something
real quick before we move on
keep going you good okay yeah um
okay we can move on from the holidays on
to some other kind of grab bag questions
um
let's let's start with this one actually
uh this is kind of a classic should a
guy
pay on the first date um
actually i want to ask the guys first uh
let's guys
let's go through all the guys do you
try to pay on the first date
i'll i it's first i do what what about
the other guys and joe just hop and say
yes or no
do you do that yep yeah yes
i do yep yes absolutely
unanimous unanimous consent here from
the guys
um so now i kind of want to get the
girls perspective on this
in terms of how does this exchange
usually go and how do you
respond to this win as all the guys in
this chat
would offer or try to pay on the first
date all right can i go
cause pearl and i had this debate today
earlier in the film
so personally i think that
the girl should offer to pay and i don't
think the man should be responsible to
pay and here's the reason why
because per at my stage in the in life
i can afford to pay for my own stuff i
can pay for afford to pay for my meal
i can even like pearl and i even talked
about like chivalry and how
men should open the door because you
know that is a sign that someone is
serious
but personally for me i don't need a
dude to do that i'm a perfectly capable
woman who can like foot the bill
what i do want to see is i want to see a
man who can emotionally support me and
john and i talked a lot about this in
our recent podcast
um which will be out soon but besides
that
i think that it also is kind of like
personally i think it i don't know why
but i feel as if
if i'm asking for and i maybe this is
just about equality in my eyes the way i
see this question is
okay how do you set the precedent for
the relationship or
is this more so like an equality thing
is this more so about or respecting is
this more so
about like chivalry and in my opinion
when i'm talking about
trying to create equality within the
relationship whether it's platonic
whether it's romantic
i want to set the precedent that i want
to be respected as a partner so that
means
i need to foot the bill as well and i
need to put my best foot forward as well
um and that's just my opinion so yeah
dante go for it so i actually just did a
video on this because i had a lot of
people asking me what i would do
and like i said i don't feel it's a
responsibility for me to pay
but i was just raised that way but what
i did
all right i'm going to continue so what
i was saying is that's just what i was
raised to do
but in my video i said i think it's
important as you said ari to like
have you know diversity or like have it
split oh so
because that said the date that i just
went on
i like what i did is i paid for dinner
and then she paid for dessert like i
think that's fair and we did that for
the rest of the time went on dates like
if we went to an event
i'd pay for the event or vice versa and
then she'd pay for whatever we do next
so we would just go back and forth and i
think that's a good balance to have
um next yeah i don't agree um sorry
i just um i don't know
i just like i'm all about women's
empowerment but i think i'm empowered to
have a standard that the guy on the
first date can pay for dinner
um like my standard for going on a date
with someone is that he can afford
dinner
um and that's totally cool if you want
to set that standard that he does
well but for me personally that's just
like
i'm not saying he has to pay for every
single thing in the relationship or like
it's like gonna be completely one-sided
but
i just find it like i don't know i
that's kind of how i was raised too
um like my brothers even my brothers
like bill always opened the door for me
they'll always like hey if we go
somewhere
well no they don't do that sorry i'm not
open to doors they want they don't
sorry that's weird but
yeah i don't know that's that's that's
for me though i don't care if ari does
that
like i just prefer it the other way well
my question is like you know i've
actually been on a date where a guy has
paid for me and he expects me to put out
and i'm like no no that's not gonna
happen and that's also why
i tend to set that precedent for okay
if we're both paying like we both are
like i you cannot expect anything out of
me
and i think that maybe that's maybe me
projecting my fears are
possible as well um but yeah i think
that
also i i think that
maybe it also has to come down to a
socio-economic thing where i
kind of feel maybe i also just feel
uncomfortable when people pay for me
that's just a general thing i don't know
if anybody else experiences that but
sometimes i just feel really
uncomfortable when people are like oh
let me get this for you i'm like
i i don't deserve this like why why are
you buying this for me why are you
paying for this for me
amanda wanted to say something so
what you just said about deserving i am
like
and this is not a non-answer i promise
i'm like actually fully split
between your two strong opinions
so there's there's a middle ground
i'm gonna talk about energy for a second
um
so there's like masculine and feminine
energy which has nothing to do with like
sex sexual orientation your preference
gender identity like
none of that it's so everyone in here
has
their own unique balance of masculine
and feminine energy
i am more masculine dominant in terms of
my mindset
like i'm very executional i like i'm
running my own company like i'm
i'm more masculine dominant with like
work
so masculine is the i do i get done
like that kind of energy where the
feminine
is that i'm soft i receive i deserve
so it's almost like the sit back and
allowing kind of energy
and so i think there's a time and a
place for both
um similar to you ari i'm like yeah for
sure like
i can pay for your dinner and i can like
bankroll you if you wanted to i'm not
going to
but if i wanted to i could so it's not
like
it's not like i'm expecting it because i
need to be taken care of it's
i deserve to be taken care of and so
that's like the worst element
i think that's that's like that's how i
feel too because i don't
i don't need someone to pay for me well
actually maybe right now
maybe even right now because i don't
have a job but like
yeah girl get that dinner then yeah
maybe maybe right now
um but like normal i don't need someone
too but like
i've just found like i have i think one
two i have five brothers
so like i've talked a lot to like guys
and like my brothers have all told me
like if it like
if he really likes you he would never
let you pay for dinner
and maybe like maybe i'm wrong i don't
know
but i just i i just i wouldn't go on a
second date with a guy who didn't pay
for dinner
but there's nothing wrong i think if
someone else wants to you know
that's just like my standard for myself
you know
yeah so i have a question for all the
guys actually
so pearl just brought up the fact that
oh this is how we would know if a guy
really likes us
but do you think that it should be more
so about
his reoccurring actions versus oh
because anybody can just open the door
anybody can just pay for dinner but it
can be
both it can be both or the other
yes but what i'm trying to say is like
do you guys think that there's more to
it like should we be looking out for
more
signs that a guy is interested in us
because
if anything like you know okay yeah
that's great you paid for my dinner
yeah that's standard but is there
something
like maybe it's not so much that but
maybe it's just emotionally being there
for them
um i know dante talks a lot about like
like you talk about oh if i'm dating you
like we're gonna do this and this and
they're and they're really those are
awesome tick tocks
um and and i don't know that maybe sets
the precedent for the type of behavior
that happens in the relationship or
what leads up to like the committing of
a relationship
i don't know i kind of want to hear what
everyone has to say sorry brian i didn't
mean to take your
role of moderator but it was just a
question that was in my head
so
i will say um in our short survey
that we just did all the guys did say
that they do
offer to pay so i don't know if actually
that indicates
a like variation of interest it just
seems like if
for the guys here at least if we're
going to go on a date with you
we will offer to pay i don't know if
that means that like i'm ten times more
interested in you or not
i don't know if there's like a threshold
i mean do you all think there's a
threshold thing or
for me it's just like if i'm gonna take
on a date i will offer to pay
probably because of like a societal
cultural norm
that we have i'd agree with that too
yeah for sure
way more than another date yeah
i think the same thing i think it's just
kind of standard knowing that i'm going
to pay for the first date
i did want to talk about that a little
bit i've had a couple where i've gone
out with someone for
like maybe three or four dates and
that's
at some point like sometimes they'll
offer to pay like oh i can get it or
we'll get
you know dinner and then we'll get
drinks at another place and they'll pay
for drinks for dessert or whatever
but i've had somewhere i went out with
them three or four times
and they never offered which was okay
but they never were
super grateful they were never like
thank you i really appreciate it like
to me that that's almost a sign of like
okay is this a gracious
person if they're not willing to not
necessarily offer but just like
thank me for paying for the dinner again
so
um to me that was a bit of a turn off
because they were almost expecting me to
to foot the bill every time so
that's kind of my explanation but but
yes i i assume i'm going to pay every
time
for at least the first couple dates i
guess
i agree with you i i think the
connection is better is it because i
moved
can you assume it right
okay perfect because i just moved in
it's better all right
so i like what brian said uh what
john said sorry i think we got to look
at it that
money is just a form of energy and it's
also a form of appreciation
of one or the other pace so
yeah with like in the society men
usually pay on the first day whatever
right but
if the woman is there for a free meal
ticket and not for you
you got to ask yourselves is the woman
excited about you
or is she excited about being taken care
of because then that is called the gold
digger
that's called someone who that's not
being taken chaos
because it's an appreciation that goes
both ways
now to make it easier i actually never
have the situation
where i never like i literally like
yeah okay maybe i'll pay the first date
right and then
i hang out with girls who are really
cool and
they will say okay i'll pay now and then
you pay and
if the girl really has no money right
she's like
and she like communicate like i'm like
yeah i'm gonna pay for the next
five six seven whatever until you're
good again
because i value you but that's not a pro
because i want to have beautiful
experiences with you
like i'm just like if i want to go jet
skiing
with the girls that i'm seeing or the
girl that i'm seeing
right but she can chime in she
that's okay because i want to have that
experience with
you and so i can and i'm excited about
that experience
so i'm going to pay for that experience
so we're having fun together but what is
the girl and that's what
ari said and i like what the question
ari said is
how do we know if someone is there for
us
right how do we know and i always say
don't watch what they say watch what
they
do now a person can also manipulate
what they do like i think pearl said
that with or ari
oh yeah you could pretend you can open
the door even though open the door is
not
a good example because that's also a
society brainwashed thing
and everybody has two hands and of
course
it's a thing of appreciation i open the
door for you because i'm stronger okay
that's fine
but it shouldn't be something that if
you make it expect expected and if you
love a person more because they do
things that i expected from society you
love the idea of the person and you
don't have a real connection to that
person
you can only have a real connection with
a person if you're excited
for that person for that character like
i love for example
a girl i'm dating right now she's super
loyal right
she's like and you can tell by all her
actions like
she is um
she's on she respects my time she
doesn't get mad like i do so many tick
tock videos i do so many like
youtube whatever right if i'm like yo
i gotta do this now and like it's early
in the morning
and like like she she might have to go
or i have to go she's not
she's like yeah she's supportive she's
like yeah do it i'm i'm proud of you i'm
excited for you
it's all good and that's the kind of
things i look for it's someone who
laughs with me it's someone who uh makes
me laugh who i make laugh who's loyal
who's not there for a free meal ticket
that's literally stupid that's low
conscious
like relationships if you are there if
you're only in the relationship
if you expect the guy to do certain
things
like my mom and dad told me a gentleman
is always
opening the door is always paying for
this it's always
wearing a suit there's some girls who
like oh he has to wear
certain stuff right how do you then
you're in love with the idea but you're
not in love with a person and i'm all
about being in love with
a person but
i think there's like a middle ground
though like i don't think
it's like you have to give me an example
like give me an example
like a specific example because it's all
like theoretical but if you give me an
example we can like talk about it tell
me
one example where you say okay this is
the middle ground
like just for me on a first date like i
just wouldn't
be cool with the guy not paying like on
a first date i'm not saying for the
entirety of the relationship
he has to like pay for everything but
like just for me personally
that's just the standard i have for
myself because i think oh no of course
and that's not what i was saying and i'm
not saying that every single person like
if arya wants to do that that's totally
cool but like i think it's okay to set
standards for women that like we deserve
to be treated a certain way or you know
maybe not even all women like
because you know not all women are nice
you know i don't know so maybe they
not not saying you're not sorry don't
take that the wrong way but like
like just for me like personally like i
just think
like if i communicate to someone that
that's the way i want to be treated like
but let's say ari and i let's say ari
and i we're not going out but let's see
ari and i go on a date right
yeah and aria is like yo i'mma pay right
she's like yo i'mma pay
it's all good she puts her credit card
down done do you think
that she first off she doesn't feel less
valued
because she's paying that's just a form
of preach like i'm just pulling down
but do you think i think uh oh
less of her no i'm going to be like next
time i'm going to be
go on a date where i'm going to be like
yo i'ma pay
like yeah that's it
it doesn't matter who pays first it's
over time it's the
energy balance like amanda talked about
masculine and feminine energy
there's also an energy balance between
two people and if someone just
is there for so to say being taken care
of
then there's no energy balance right i
think
i think you're saying it should be 50 50
right like i think you're saying like
like you should have like
equal energy however you want to like
measure that right yeah
yeah yeah and i agree with you i just
like for me like the standard to go out
with me
personally is like the first couple
dates you have to pay i'm not saying he
has to pay for every single thing but
especially if you ask
me out like you asked me to come you
know let me ask okay let me ask you that
okay no no
i don't i usually pay on the first but
it's not even about that
i i usually pay on let me ask you this
like let's say you go out you said the
first couple days usually they must pay
right
let's say you go out with like the
coolest guy you have so much fun he
makes you laugh
right he pays the first date you go on
the second date you go to the movies you
have so much fun you have a great
conversation
and then you go to dinner and he's like
uh
you pay like 50 50. and then you like
this is like the dopest guy you met like
for a longest time
i don't think you're gonna like my
answer and you got
you are you really gonna be like [ __ ]
you
okay did he ask me to dinner if he asked
me
to dinner you asked me to go
let dante go let down so pearl you're
saying if a guy asks you out you should
be obligated to pay correct yeah
so let's say you ask a guy are you not
obligated to pay
no why not why not i don't know
where's the balance in that that's what
i'm saying because it sounds like an
entitlement thing to me not just you
personally but i've heard other girls
say that
but why like what do you mean
like why if he has to pick you if he
asks you out why don't you have to pay
for him if you ask him out
i just feel like that's the standard i
have for me and if you don't like if you
don't have that scene that's what i'm
asking though is like
why yeah it's not a standard it's a
story you have in your mind
about how you feel a a guy you
like should act it's not a standard it's
literally a trained
thing but it's okay because that's your
preference
i'm not taking away your preference if
that's what you want to do i'm just
saying
that i don't see a balance in that
but if that's your preference you will
find someone who will do that
right but this is not even important
like literally is that
you guys set priorities is that really
important
so the hypothetical question you said it
was like third or fourth date
i don't know first date i wouldn't be
cool with it later down the road maybe
it's about how that person is right it's
about how
that person is all together as
a person it's not mathematically it's
not a mathematical structure
like you count in your head oh i'm gonna
pay the
he's gonna pay the first three days the
first four days and then i'm gonna pay
for one
and then he's gonna pay three dates
again and then if you
have this head connection it's always
gonna be a relationship that's going to
be in your head
but if it's really a person like i had
girls like literally where i was like
making
more money too and they were like
struggling right now right
but i didn't feel like i was giving
something
away from me when i like just was like i
invited her for like
like a month or even like seven weeks
straight and
even on because she was so cool she was
like man i really don't like you doing
this
but i was like that's exactly why i'm
doing it because you don't expect it for
me
you don't expect it for me but as soon
as
you raise the law that's not real love
so
to be honest like i don't even really
like going to dinner i feel like if i
could go on a date i'd just play
basketball
i don't know about like like yeah i like
that answer
like to be honest like i feel like my
ideal dates don't cost anything i go
like hiking maybe play basketball
i love that that's great dates yeah hey
i'll i'll kill you in one-on-one because
i played in college you know what i mean
real quick i kind of before casey chimes
in
um i want to just kind of talk about my
date yesterday
because i walked into so i ubered over
to this guy's place he doesn't have cope
and by the way he showed me his antibody
test
and i walked it i i basically walked to
his apartment and he texted me he's like
hey can't come to the door right now
i'm like why he goes i'm playing cop do
you leave immediately
no i didn't leave immediately but i have
a video you should have
really okay because like i basically
i had walked in there and he was like he
buzzed me and he didn't even get the
door
and then i have a video of him playing
cod
as i'm sitting there watching him and
like okay
what do i do but um yeah i don't know
it's kind of like
it was a it's a very i feel like during
the day you don't really know what to
think
and then like especially for how like
men should treat you especially with
heterosexual
relationships but i didn't realize until
like in retrospect
that oh my god maybe like
this is where pearl's coming in where
it's like okay maybe the guy should have
gotten the door maybe the guy should
have like
because in that moment i really did feel
like really disrespected
i don't know but also did you meet him
on tinder or what
no we had met we had met so he we have
mutual friends or whatever and we also
met on a dating app through that because
essence is a very small city but
um yeah i don't use tinder in your past
relationships already did the guys
did the guys get the door for you did
they come to the door like were they
more respectful
than that or no yeah they were yeah i'd
say so
so would you say that's like what you
expect from yourself as a guy to do that
or no
i feel like i don't really know
because i haven't been in a relationship
in a that's the problem
yeah if you know what you deserve and
you know what you're worth then you're
gonna know that [ __ ] right when it
happens that's my point
that is true yeah maybe i should have
walked i don't know and then
and then during the day i was like oh
this is actually like not that bad
but oh my god it just the red flag just
kept coming out and i was like
i don't know casey needs to like speak
so i want to let him and then we'll get
back to my day um afterward
cause i gotta tell i gotta spill the tea
for you guys because it's really funny
sounds good i have to just go teach here
in just a moment so just so i can
contribute something to this
i think what we can see is
communication plays a really big role
and even when it comes to things like
asking either someone out to dinner or
paying for that dinner
because at least as a guy i hope that me
offering to pay for dinner or me just
trying to pay the bill i hope that does
not just automatically convey interest
for example i took a staff member of
mine that's on my journal out to dinner
the other day as a thank you
and i did that simply as a professional
courtesy
and it's very interesting how even today
certain gestures are always associated
with romantic
interests and we can see now that
even with all of us it's we all have
different opinions on
how people should treat each other and
i think at the end of the day maybe the
the one common thing that we can all
work on
or that we should all try to focus on
when it comes to
dating or even going out for a meal or a
drink
is communicating what our interests are
because if we
communicate what our interests are no
matter what happens no matter who pays
you know everyone's not going to be
second guessing at the end of each
evening so i think that would be super
helpful and that's something that i need
to work on as well
and thank you everyone it was nice to
meet everyone i do have to go teach some
constitutional law though
i like what she said you're like a mini
barack
um bye casey oh he already left um what
i was gonna say is like during that date
there were moments where the first the
first red flag was
i walk in he's like i
like i'm playing cod i was sitting there
for 10 minutes watching him play
and then he gets into his dating history
and he's like i don't like princess type
girls
i was like what do you mean by princess
type he goes yeah the girl's like i had
one of my girlfriends who
basically said to me i want to design a
stroller and i want to live in noe
valley which is a really prominent
neighborhood in sf and then i'm like
okay
and basically i was like lol like do you
basically and maybe this comes down to
expectations versus like
you know having this attitude where you
deserve things and maybe that's like
where
we need to as like just people in
general not gender but like people in
general need to like knock themselves a
few pegs down but then this guy was like
talking all about finance and like
talking about how he's like
selling his debt to asset ratios and
he's in private equity i'm not going to
include that and
you guys might want to take that out
because it's kind of confidential but
basically talking about oh like
pretty much was the worst day i've ever
been on because he was like at 11
38 p.m on a monday night he was like do
you want to do some cocaine i'm like
no i'm good and then he was like
oh yeah basically talking about how his
past girlfriends have daddy issues and
like i don't know i was like enjoying
the conversation because
he he opened up about a lot of really
intimate things maybe he was opening up
too much about it
i don't know but also because i
specialize in relationship advice i was
giving him advice
but basically it turned into me like
listening to this guy talk about his
life problems
talk about his job talk about and then
offer me drugs which i was like no thank
you
and then yeah i i felt
like really weird walking out of the
date because it seemed like fun it was
fun like i was talking to him i had a
really good conversation
but like at the same time i feel kind of
felt so confused because there were so
many red flags in retrospect
and i would have never really realized
that like
um yeah uh yeah i don't know
i i didn't like if i hadn't known about
what i do
now i feel like i wouldn't have pointed
out those red flags but to go back to
the whole the original question of how
do we know if a guy likes us
i kind of am just confused because i'm
like okay
i this guy clearly likes me but his
behavior
because he he texted me that i said he's
like hey like let's hang a guy oh yeah
i'm like no thanks
but his behavior really points to the
fact that
he needs to work on something or you
know like is this how he
always treats his dates you know um so
yeah
the question i have is are you attracted
to him
no physically yes but emotionally no
well i do you want to go out with him
again
are you going to go out with him again
okay because if you said yes i would
have said
okay everything that you done worked
to get you yeah yeah
i just it was like i don't know if you
guys have had some really
bad days i was like bro what the [ __ ]
just happened like walking out of there
i was like oh my god
um but yeah i don't know i i feel like
so also having dated in san francisco
weirdly have a very similar date
experience like
years ago it's not the same guy i
promise um
i'm still in finance shocker um so
so here's one perspective is like
i i'm down or there was a period of time
where i was like super down for those
kind of dates because like
i was kind of having like hot girl
summer you know like
if i'm if i'm authentically in a place
where i don't want a relationship
i don't let those flags bother me
because i know that it's not going to be
long term and i'm
there's no reason for me to be overly
emotionally invested
i think where people get tripped up is
when we're
so starved or like so subconsciously
desiring love that we overlook red flags
pretend that we are
not looking for something when on a
deeper level we are and then all of a
sudden
you've like knocked yourself into this
corner where you're
saying some flags are okay and you're
still seeing someone who's like maybe
not treating you as well as you want
and then all of a sudden you're in this
like weird confusing situation
and i'm talking to the general you not
like ari you
obviously but like it i think
comes down to like preference and being
super [ __ ] on it
can i say [ __ ] i did it twice
okay uh we uh [ __ ] [ __ ] tits
freaking honest um just like honest with
yourself
like what am i like legitimately open to
and down for right now
and the second you start to feel like
yeah that was not cool and i don't want
to repeat that again
if you want to like really make that
actionable it's like okay let me just
pause for a sec
look at what specifically it was that
bothered me
not the actions not like oh he was on
call of duty
you get to the root emotion it's like
wow
there was a vacancy of respect there or
i didn't feel like i was seen
and if you're in a place where you want
something more serious those qualities
respect and being seen
it's like cool that person doesn't
fulfill those again if you're like
whatever you're hot like let's just go
have some fun totally different ball
game
but i don't think enough people are
honest with themselves and each other
i think uh someone maybe it was casey
before he left was saying something
about communication like
communication with yourself first you
know
also wild with the 8 p.m coke
opportunities
i don't know why that's such a thing in
sf honestly
this i think it's just finance froze
maybe it's very i'm not thrilled
but i just yeah i i feel
i don't know how it came up i was like
what the hell and he's like oh don't
worry like
and basically was talking about i i
shouldn't really be talking about this
on
because it's a recorded zoom call
whatever we can edit give us the t
yeah um yeah no he was just talking
about like oh yeah
i have a i have a connect to the like
cartel and i was like
what and it was like okay
and basically it was like run and yeah
and he was telling
all the stuff he's like yeah like i
worked and this firm and like this would
have been all over the headlines i was
like oh my god like this is
like crazy [ __ ] and i don't know i this
also kind of
makes me qui like this is a question for
the guys but you know
when a girl isn't interested or we just
like feel like
weird about leaving or we want to leave
the
date but we don't want to hurt anyone's
feelings because i'm very like
passive sometimes like in that moment i
was like do i leave like what do i
say like what should we do because like
i don't know
wild nightfall wild monday night
obviously
i think obviously the like the
most realistic thing or like the most
honest thing to do is like
let that person know but i think it's
just like since you're already in that
situation
it's kind of tough to because at the end
of the day if you don't want to be there
um like that's just not wasting your
time it's kind of wasting that other
person's time
because if you're not connecting you
don't want to be there then like
that just means that um things weren't
going to happen
um regardless so i think it's just
important just to be
open and honest even though i know how
tough it can be since you're already in
that situation
you already said yes like you're already
there but um
at least maybe if you just do decide to
stay there just at the end the night
or the day after kind of just be open
and honest because i think
i'm just kind of ripping off a band-aid
would be like the best way to
kind of resort it yeah very worried
that's a good it's good that's good yeah
i did that
uh i did that actually before can you
guys hear me yeah cause i changed my
yeah
um i actually um years ago i was on a
i don't go on tinder dates anymore but i
wasn't attending date
and i met her and she didn't first thing
she didn't look like the pictures
and um and then i was like okay
maybe she could like maybe she's good
she's gonna be a friend whatever then we
walked and
we clearly had different preferences
like we just talked communicated
and i realized okay this is not like
a friend and this is not going to date
and this is not my excitement it's not
my preference
and like um sorry albert elbert said
like you wanna what i feel like is
if you let a person know what you want
and
then they can choose if they want to
stay or not and if both can communicate
that
it's better than staying in a situation
you don't want to be in so i just said
hey
i feel like you and me were different um
and i think
we should just like move our different
ways and she was like
i love that you just said that you
are so honest and
that you communicated that and i loved
that and then i was like okay cool
and then she was like oh but do you
wanna still gonna go in the in the store
with me and i was like
no i'm good and
she was i don't know but it seemed like
she was even more attractive afterwards
but i feel like it's way better because
then
she knew i knew and we both go to what
excites us
brian you want to go does anybody else
want to chime in
i mean i agree with like the honesty um
one time i was on a date and a guy just
like it was kind of awkward
and this guy looked at me he's like i
literally don't know what to say right
now and for some reason like
i was like i don't know i just respected
it it was like
i don't know sometimes i feel like when
people are open and honest it just makes
like because i was just says what
everyone's thinking almost
i don't know i can agree disagree but
uh there's been i mean usually i'll just
say like hey i'm gonna head out
like kind of casual and then you don't
really have to say why because you can
go and choose as you please just say i'm
gonna head out
there's there's been a couple more
awkward where i was like
i just wasn't feeling it and so i was
like hey uh it's getting late i'm gonna
go home
and then she said something equivalent
of like
you know you can stay here right and
then i was like
we had been kind of drinking a little
bit so it's like kind of buzzed but then
like
have you ever watched anime where like
the main character just gets a moment of
clarity and i was like
whatever i say now will determine the
rest of my life
and then proceeds to happen the dumbest
[ __ ] ever comes out of my mouth so she's
like
you know you can stay here right and i
was like well
you know sf rent is too high and i
should just like i pay a lot for my bed
and i should just like go to that
and i said probably the dumbest [ __ ] in
the dumbest way but that [ __ ] worked
because like what was she supposed to
she was like yeah i know
it's like really expensive here and we
started talking about rent and then i
pissed out after that
um so i don't know if that's the best
way to do it
but that's how i feel like if i wasn't
feeling i'm just like
i usually go for like the derpy dumb
thing just like uh no it's all good cool
see you later um had a good time stuff
like that
uh i i just i joke things off so i just
tried not to make it too serious and i
think in the circumstance it didn't come
off as like
i don't like this or like i don't want
to be here in that way
you know brian that kind of brings back
a jarring memory of mine when i have a
sudden date and
um i didn't really like the guy so i
pretended that i had
explosive diarrhea so i
was like can't come out of the bathroom
like i thought it's really better i was
like
you should just leave like it's really
bad
it's not my best move i hope he's not
watching this like i hope he doesn't
watch this
but yeah i've had some really bad date
excuses like i've had to have my mom
call me during a date while i was at the
california academy of sciences and be
like
yeah you gotta come home like you have
family problem
or like i've had a friend call me before
i've had to fake a cramp before um
i'm not proud of that okay but yeah
can i chime in um yeah okay ari i feel
like you and i are
similar to that i haven't made any like
i've never used explosive diarrhea to
get out of a date
but i feel like there's like i will hang
out longer than i want to
and i will i used to be like a really
strong people pleaser so i don't wanna
i don't wanna make him upset i don't
want to it's almost like i'm stuck on
this date that i don't want to be on
and we can kind of both feel it so i can
totally relate to
where you're at but i think at the same
time it's like if it's a first date
or even if you don't have a relationship
with this person
you don't really owe them an explanation
or anything and i think that
part of it's just like hey i think i'm
gonna head out um hey i'm gonna go or
whatever it is and if they want an
explanation
you could then address it then or
another thing that we do because we can
communicate through
text and messages and all that stuff
it's like you know what i'm i'm not
exactly sure
i'm not really feeling it but i'll i'll
communicate to you later so that way you
can still at least tell them
hey i just didn't think i want to be
there any longer or you then you can be
honest with them and in the moment it
might be really scary to be honest with
them
but at some point like when you kind of
get to the point where you can be honest
with someone and kind at the same time
that's where you can really be like hey
i've you know i
i've enjoyed hanging out with you you
know i'm feeling uncomfortable or this
or that and then you can
speak that truth speak your honesty to
them that way
um as a former excuse maker
i will say like what john said about
getting to the point where you can
communicate and exit in an honest but
kind way
is like really liberating um
my like little baby people pleaser was
like oh i should just stay because like
i don't want to seem like a [ __ ] or
whatev
it doesn't have to be about like i'm a
dick or i'm a [ __ ]
it doesn't have to be about that it's
like no i'm just like not feeling it
and i'll share like a story where i was
i was supposed to be on a date but this
guy brought his
two friends which is fine like i'm down
to meet your friends
but they were both very like
just strange in a lot of different ways
without going into it it was just a real
weird dynamic i was on a date with like
three people
didn't know what was going on and there
was a point where i was like
the guy wasn't even talking to me it was
just so weird we were like sitting at a
table the three of us
not talking and i i waved like
do i have it in my mind and like the
energy in my body to just stick it out
until like 11 p.m
and the guy went to the bathroom and
a lady next to me 50s or 60s turns to me
and she goes are you looking to leave
this date
and i was like yeah i was like i don't
know 22
3 at the time and i was like oh my god
yeah i don't know what to do and she was
like honey
learn this lesson right now leave it's
okay
i heard the way that he was and wasn't
talking to you say you're leaving and
then go
and i was like okay like it was weird
cuz i needed permission from
someone else at first they did it and
then i've never
like made excuses again because it was
so liberating
to be like oh no i can like choose i
don't have to be resentful for like
being kept on this date i can just like
say no i'm not feeling it and like
actually walk away
it can be scary though like i i get that
and it's also kind of funny to like have
the stories of the excuses like are you
know you're never gonna forget that
um but i think at some point like we
ultimately have to come to that level of
self-honesty like
how long do i have to sit this out for i
can just like be clear and kind and
we can kind of go our separate ways or
an old lady next
you can get the [ __ ] out and you can go
she was a messenger i love it
i know i would have bro uh star are you
in uh
l.a yes i'm in uh venice beach
so this this particular date happened on
a
main street in santa monica at uh god
the bar
it doesn't matter but it's like right
across from the cvs like down the road a
little bit it was right there that's
crazy i'm on main street right now
it was literally right where you are
main street
right here that's crazy oh my old hood i
miss it
ready brian you wanna
yeah well we're coming up at like an
hour and a half so
i was going to just kind of like wrap it
um is there anybody else who wants to
say any final things i personally have
to head out soon
um as well um but already order is any
final things
yeah um obviously like this and the
entire structure was a little
disorganized
and i want to make sure that everyone
speaks but i
kind of wanted to ask everyone
like personally while we're here you
know is there something that we can do
where we're making sure that everyone's
engaged we're talking more in depth
about the issues that we personally
specialize in because
i feel like i just offered some really
broad questions
and i would like for everyone to have
the floor but also
uh i don't want this to be like feel
like people have like
it's like like a waste of time or
whatever you know um
because some people are more quiet than
others and yeah
can i chime in on that yeah go for it so
um
yeah i think the format is great i think
that uh a couple things that could help
it move a little bit smoother
because i've done some of these in the
past is um trying to have like a target
window of like if you have
45 seconds to respond
usually that 40 some people might take
30 seconds i might talk 30 seconds but
someone might take like a minute
or up to like a minute 15. so if we
count over more
and we don't have to say 45 seconds but
whatever that time frame is
yeah and then if the moderator is kind
of like okay all right john go ahead and
then we're gonna hear from dante
and then we're gonna hear from casey so
then so that way it's kind of people
know who's coming up next
and um so if the moderator is a little
bit more active in kind of
controlling kind of who's talking and
then um let's say there is a
conversation like with
star and pearl it's like okay all right
you know what this conversation's really
good let's let's go back and forth
you guys can kind of hash that
conversation out because there was some
really good
um i feel like it was a really good
conversation so that's kind of my
that'd be my input i guess i really like
that
um my other question is i know like
so dante jackson and albert you guys can
talk that much is there something that
we can do so we're engaging you guys a
little bit more
um i would just say i mean like i was
kind of just listening to a lot of it
because i got a lot of good stuff out of
this too
but um i like the conversation i don't
think i don't think we should like
make sure everyone has this like
specific time to talk because i think
like that conversation between pearl
and star would have never happened if
that was if that was the case
and i think that was like one of the
best like i don't know about anyone else
like that was one of the best moments of
the night like i was
the most informative and you get both
points both people like
like not coming at each other but kind
of like going at each other a little bit
and like that's when you really find out
like
this is this is the advice that we need
like this is two different people from
different two different spectrums like
kind of
like going back and forth and i think
that's good i mean
i'll talk more in the future but i just
i got a lot of good stuff out of this so
yeah i ideally i agree
[Music]
yeah sorry yeah i agree too i just
sorry about that but um yeah i think
i'll just like i just kind of try and
chime in with things that i can actually
like relate to or
have a knowledgeable answer and stuff
like that so
um don't want to like overstep or just
say something that
wouldn't really make sense so i kind of
just chime in when i can basically
okay i think what i'm going to do
personally is i'm going to go to
everyone like before i'll make it more
organized and ask them like what do you
want to talk about this week and kind of
consolidate it
and then like pearl and i can work
together and just kind of figure
something out
um but yeah that's ideally like what i'm
i want everyone to have their worth and
like
get something out of this so i just like
i'm worried that okay maybe you're just
you don't feel like you are so that's
why i'm asking questions and i don't
know does
everyone feel like there could be
something else that's done differently
and
um i was wondering if like it makes
sense
not always but maybe here and there we
did like a smaller group like with like
a couple people that maybe have like an
opinion on something or like put the
coaches together
i don't know just throwing ideas out
there like just
because then like they'd have more talk
time and then they'd have like a
conversation with something that's like
i don't know
relevant i like that maybe from time to
time do a big group
and a smaller group because i like the
big group because it's like so many
opinions and people listen
and yeah maybe like do both because
if it's a big group there's always
someone who's inspired
to talk yeah
i like that and yeah i'm gonna try to
figure out infrastructure
and once again i really appreciate
everyone coming out tonight like and
um still trying to get things together i
apologize that
it's kind of disorganized but yeah
yeah and we're getting to know each
other which is cool right i mean this is
the first time this is our first time we
got to give ourselves like some props
like
we never really talked together and we
didn't fight
we stayed cool and it's gonna just get
better and better literally like
and maybe some of us become friends and
like closer friends and
i i like it it's a cool journey you know
second that well said star
yeah sounds good it was nice to meet
y'all um i got ahead personally
but if y'all want to stay in chat that's
that's chill
um i know bye brian thanks for thanks
for moderating
if you have complaints with my
moderation
you can you can message me directly
because i don't email them to ari
flutter at
flutter dating i don't need you all to
just come at me in the general
black chat like tell me personally and i
will respond to your complaints
don't just put me on blast like that i
will react
just letting you know bye
bye brian um just a few more
housekeeping things
uh i am putting together a brand toolkit
and i have some meetings with some other
brands as well
next week um so i will just basically
give you guys
a heads up on who i'm meeting the urban
mate thing still working on it
they want me to like piece together
their entire
mission and whatnot and like kind of
regurgitate it so i need to really do
that research
um i'm mailing these out tomorrow by the
way i wrote everyone's letters and
everything so
i have to like basically do that um is
there anything that anyone would like to
talk about like or anything any ideas
before
we head out
i just have one thing um and i don't
know how to
really intellectualize that but maybe i
do
um that we
for next time or like that that's just
one of my wishes
to come more of like a foundation
why people don't feel that good in
relationships or why people
instead of like looking outside all the
time being like oh
the other person this is how a person
should behave this is how a person
should behave
this how a person should behave like
talk more about
also why how do i feel inside like
and how would making me feel more whole
make the entire relationship better
that makes sense yeah i think that
a lot of us really do a deep dive and a
lot of
our and a lot of things that we talk
about um dante talks a lot about women's
empowerment jackson talks a lot more
about you know like
um i've noticed that he talks a lot more
about being positive and also kind of
looking on the bright side of things but
also being really real
john also talks about you know how do
you go from
it's your pathway to
personal freedom personal freedom right
amanda talks a lot about anxiety and
goes in depth and then albert is also
talking about you know
him and his mom like in doing like more
relationship events
and then pearl talks more about like you
know the the
um the service that she does in star
like really goes in depth with like some
very like spiritual but also just really
great issues that
or calls people out and i think that
like maybe i just asked too many
subjective questions and i should
have like i said and originally like i
should have
consulted everyone but i was kind of
like in a rush because power got shut
off but that's not an excuse
but i think what i'm gonna do is just
basically
kind of makes it so that we're asking
more deep level
deeper level questions so that we can
have a conversation less questions and
more conversation
yeah a question um uh i would love for
next time would be like
how do you feel like your emotional
health affects
the entire relationship like something
like that you know yeah
um do you when do you guys want to shoot
again do you know this is one last thing
by the way
i like tuesdays or thursdays i just
can't do monday or wednesday
okay okay you guys work for me as well
my schedule's like so busy right now um
but i'll try to squeeze in we'll see
hey you're working hard pearl we see you
thank you thank you i told my mom i'm a
tic tac star but she doesn't she doesn't
really think
like the same hey i'd hire you
oh you're talking about that video yeah
okay um i think that's it for now
and then i'll basically upload this to
the dropbox and
uh yeah
bro i'm gonna post that video because
i'm curious to get other people's
perspective
are you okay with that are you asking me
no pro which oh i'm gonna post like
if a guy pays for a girl on the first
stage to go pay for a guy i'm just
curious i just want people's perspective
oh i don't care
you call that all right yeah cool okay
everyone
is any last thoughts words
final dying wishes so are we posting
this
ourselves or like
because dante just asked if everyone's
okay
if you post um that conversation right
oh i'm just gonna record myself asking
it i'm not gonna post like i was talking
about it
i mean i don't care if you guys wanna
post i disagree like you're allowed to
disagree with me i don't care
i'm just curious i just want people's
feedback okay now again
so what i'm just gonna do is i'm just
gonna upload the raw footage to dropbox
and then you guys can use it on your
computers and edit it however you want
just yeah i might take out the whole uh
bit about my date because yeah
you don't want us exposing you that's
crazy
what person we will never
okay um all right thanks guys
so much